québec va recommander de porter un
masque dans les transports en commun ou
au travail si la distance de 2 mètres
entre les personnes ne peut pas être
respecté marie-eve caron et présidente
du mana qui vient de développer un
masque en petits microbes bien bonsoir
madame caron généralement vous fabriquez
quoi des vêtements affaissé des produits
de partage donc des ports dvi ou
champêtres pour à pau destiné aux
prématurés ou nous voler le conte avait
comme produit le pari les années passent
effectivement et là vous avez décidé de
fabriquer des masques a fait oui on a
décidé de pivoter un peu notre
entreprise
moi j'avais des collègues professionnels
de la santé pharmaciens et dans d'autres
domaines connexes qui m'ont contacté à
plusieurs reprises à savoir si j'allais
produire des masques étant donné que
j'ai accès plancher de production
lesaint devenu une question qui devait
être inévitable au sein de l'équipe
oui et donc parlez nous de ce masque que
vous avez développé à fait nous quand on
a commencé le le processus de conception
de design du masque on avait des
variables des paramètres qu'on voulait
contrôler parce qu'on s'adresse quand
même un marché de travailleurs donc il
ya vraiment une différence entre
monsieur bonhomme si je peux me
permettre l'exemple qui valent à
l'épicerie pour une période de 45
minutes et madame wyeth qui va vouloir
l'utiliser sur une période de dix huit
arles pour encore de travail donc le
paramètre de respirabilité pour nous
était vraiment important et la
filtration bactérienne est aussi un
autre paramètre qui l'est tout autant
et quand on veut avoir le maximum de
filtration généralement on va diminuer
notre capacité de respirabilité
donc pour moi dans la conception de ce
masque lost est d'arriver à un équilibre
d'avoir le meilleur des deux mondes si
on veut et de pouvoir assurer une
sécurité avec la sq en question vous
lever dans les mains présentement face à
senna oui je montre elle est un peu un
peu devant vous là qu'on le voit sa
fille le masque donc que vous avez
développé et vous en avez de différentes
couleurs ou pour l'instant non comment
elle reste quand même un marché d'une
capacité de production ses vingt-cinq
mille unités par semaine pour assurer
une productivité
fos pou limiter un petit peu la ligue
les couleurs les design et il ya tout
une question d'approvisionnement je vous
cacherais pas qu'actuellement tout ce
qui est bien qu'à eric issue élastique
beaucoup beaucoup de composantes
deviennent bo est pas juste au québec au
canada à travers le monde
bo ça veut dire quoi ça les besoins
d'encadrement du oui oui nous ont
sécurisé le pour les prochaines semaines
à venir parce qu'on avait déjà des
contrats avec des entreprises le qui est
en discussion on savait qu'on allait
avoir un fils de production d'un 5000
unités minimalement par semaine mais je
vois des collègues et des amis les
entrepreneurs le qui malheureusement ont
pas accès à toutes leurs matières
premières est un enjeu majeur dans le
secteur actuel
donc est-ce que vous avez vous des
employés dans leur fabrication
oui oui on est une équipe actuellement
on est à voir à monter un deuxième
plancher production dans la région de
l'estrie
on aimerait faire appel notamment au
cercle des fermières à tous ces femmes
qui ont fait la couture pendant
plusieurs années pour pouvoir le faire
grandir cette équipe et répondre à la
demande donc vous embaucher ce soir et
notre projet oui
donc il va pour à des gens qui on sait
pas faire de la couture c'est ça
l'acte effectivement est ce que vous
devez faire homologuer votre ce match
que la parfaite et canada de ce que moi
j'ai compris dans vos processus de
conception puis avec l'équipe qui
m'entoure les ressources notamment le
créneau à caen textile le groupe cet été
à saint-hyacinthe
on a beaucoup d'expérience québec dans
le domaine du textile
on oublie qu'il y a plusieurs années on
avait quand même de grosses usines ici
donc tout ce qui masque de tissus
d'arriver à avoir des performances qui
répondent aux standards de santé canada
pour pouvoir être homologué par exemple
pour un niveau 1 2 et c'est extrêmement
difficile donc il faut avoir l'humilité
de présenter je crois nos résultats test
donc notre respirabilité ne te capacités
de performance de filtration
toutefois prétendre arriver à être
l'équivalent de deux petits coups meetic
et ses masques on comprend qu'ils sont
lavables ils sauront ils sont bons pour
combien de temps nous dans notre cas là
les matières premières qu on a choisi
nous permettre de statuer qu'on peut la
vie de masques jusqu'à 75 fois sans
altérer les propriétés du masque combien
en route votre masque 10 $ 10 $ et donc
ça va être rentable pour vous de faire
ça vous venez de développer un nouveau
marché absolument absolument rentable
win
par contre on souhaite quand même
remettre une partie nous nos profits
après mac et becky la fondation et de
l'abbé notamment mais simplement d'un
point de vue économique pour les
entreprises vont savoir qu'une
entreprise que plusieurs milliers
d'employés
c'est une dépense substantielles qui
vient d'arriver qui était possiblement
même pas prévu quand on peut comparer
par exemple avec les masques jetables
donc un masque jetable aujourd'hui votre
détails autour d'eux en dollars 25 ans
de leur 50 et trois masques sont
nécessaires par jour par l'employé donc
sur une période de 75 jours on parle
d'une dépense de 2250 dollar environ
pour les masques jetables et quand on
tombe dans les masques réutilise hermes
on parle de 30 $ par employé pour la
même durée donc je pense que vraiment un
aspect aussi économique non seulement
pour relancer l'économie
dans le domaine manufacturier textile ou
québec gagné beaucoup d'autonomie mais
aussi offrir une alternative le beaucoup
plus économique pour l'entreprise
vous êtes un exemple très stimulant je
dirais dans tout cela parce que quand
même beaucoup de mauvaises nouvelles et
de tristesse pour bien des gens mais
c'est très encourageant de voir des
entrepreneurs comme vous merci madame
caron bonne chance et bon courage
merci